the most valuable skill that you can
have in order is product first then
marketing then sales and so right now if
you know how to sell it's because you
don't know how to Market you know how to
build products if you know how to market
then you can sell lots of stuff but
you're only going to sell it once
because the product's usually not that
good if you know how to sell product
you'll get more promotion from your
customers than anything else and that is
ultimately what scales the Enterprise
marketing can scale anything to a point
and then what happens is the marginal
cost of getting the next customer
continues to get oh up and up and if you
don't get Word of Mouth referrals from
customers who use your product then
eventually it becomes untenable and your
company will Plateau and so the key to
building a very very big thing that
lasts for a very long time is have an
exceptional product